From now on
, I'm going to get sick if I skip even one day.
I mean, he came all the way to the office today,
but it didn't help me.
I wanted to repay the debt.
When I went to the club, my
seniors would have
come to stop me from being forced to drink
.
[Music]
Fans and wow
, it
was my fault that I was guided instead of me.
Fortunately, why did
I have the theme at that time? I
can't say to such a dad, and I could
n't help ame because I didn't have any friends to talk to.
I know it's because
I've
been watching it for a long time
1 I've been cheering for you
Cute kid list What are you talking about What are you stupid
?  I'll keep you young. I
'll get you back from time to time
.